- Okay, do you have any
plans for Valentine's Day?
Are you one of those
people that goes all out?
- We do, we definitely eat a
lot together always, pasta.
- That's like a day the
ends in Y in my house.
- Yeah, we'll just binge and drink.
- What are you drinking?
- Just wine.
- Okay.
- Red girl, white girl?
Just curious.
- Red, for sure.
- Nice, me too.
Pinot noir.
- Pinot noir, yeah.
- I heard something about you though,
that you've always wanted
to be a mom, right?
- Yes, and we are doing
IVF right now actually.
(audience cheering)
- Thanks, thank you.
- And that's like, it
sounds like just a process
'cause so many people go through it now.
It sounds like a process,
but it's kinda hardcore.
I've had friends go through that.
- Yeah, yeah.
So this Valentine's Day,
I'll be getting shots in
my butt by my husband.
(Kelly laughs)
- Hormones.
- Very romantic.
Yes, hormones.
But the hormones are very intense.
And you know, so many
people, they go through this.
- [Kelly] So many.
- And we don't talk about
it enough, I think, as women
and we need to raise more understanding
and awareness behind it.
- And I'm glad, that's why I was so happy
you wanted to talk about this today
because I have friends who went through it
and I mean, went through
some serious depression,
felt shame, was like
"What was wrong with me?"
Like, tried everything under the sun.
And sometimes, it just doesn't happen
and you just need science to
kind of help move it along.
- Yeah, and it's actually such
a miracle what they can do.
Like, that's a miracle in of itself.
- Agreed.
Did you always picture
yourself being a mom?
- Yeah, definitely.
- You're the baby of the family
and you always wanted kids?
We're like, opposite humans.
- No, I'm the older sister,
- Oh, you're the old.. that makes sense.
Okay.
- But I had a little baby
carriage that I would,
you know, and a baby doll.
- That was my sister and
then she'd curl my hair
and accidentally burn me.
It was fine.
- Yeah, I cut my sister's bangs a lot.
- Yeah, that's what my sister would do.